I've been kicked around the kitchens by
Malaysian auntie's I've tried pure Malay
Chinese Malay but I'm yet to express
Indian fusion
[Music]
so put my faith in a Buddhist temple
famous for its curries one in five
Malaysians is a Buddhist and tomorrow as
we saw
that's Buddha's birthday to you and me
[Music]
place is amazing put his birthday
tomorrow so shoe celebration 10,000
guests arriving
[Music]
the temple staff are preparing a
super-sized feast and a volunteer to
help
I've been someone to see the chief monk
he wants to make sure that I'm up to the
task of cooking for a very important
guest of honor
yeah good to see to be here a little bit
nervous about 10,000 guests arriving
tomorrow to celebrate tomorrow our
honorable Prime Minister of Malaysia
really yes he's coming to join with us
I hope you prepare them one or two
dishes for him yes and his wife Raisa I
won't pry
the like macaroni or hunting macaroni Oh
thumping macaroni I'm in Malaysia not
Eastern the London no macaroni and
cheese now it means so much for me to
cook a Malaysian style Indian curry and
to bring macaroni and cheese over and
they give you a blessing for you please
thank you I understand something do get
a little bit angry chief you don't watch
television do I mean yeah I can't watch
oh you heard okay yeah so you must not
do any evil thing you must try your best
to do good things yes you must think try
your best thing good things rice don't
go to extreme minute okay how good
masters advice
everything in middle path or the middle
path middle path nice to meet you thank
you that you try your best not to get
angry now so I give you some some
souvenir you can see my photo
yeah that's amazing I've got a pen like
that bruise with a new lady you turn
upside down that bikini comes down but
that's the hot people thought and I'll
keep that for later likes it chief
pleasure the bit that freaked me out is
when he asked me to cook macaroni and
cheese [ __ ] macaroni and cheese for
the Prime Minister
I'll get shot change my opinion on
Buddhism not as yet no although it may
be worthwhile doing it one day for these
little beauties here pens like that that
fly like that or you know it's just
hilarious
[Music]
I want to check out the kitchen that'll
be cooking in tomorrow and it's run by
another auntie mrs. Roopa how are you
nice to see you thank you actually when
did you guys start tonight when was it I
stopped and you could be working
throughout the night mrs. brimmer's been
cooking here for 25 years and she's used
to catering for big crowds so where's
the where's the big kitchen this is the
big kitchen yes is it well for 10,000
guests yeah because it's Buddha's
birthday everything on the menu has to
be vegetarian and that's not a prospect
I relish
say yes you're gonna love it
it's not fantastic but it's not bad
maybe the monks macaroni wasn't such a
bonkers idea after all gotta respect
what they're doing however you know it's
vegetarian food and it's not the most
glamorous the best of time so gonna make
it into something magical with the help
of mrs. Rupa
[Music]
I'm midway through my Great Escape to
Malaysia and I've discovered a cuisine
that's one of the most complex I've ever
encountered
today it's Buddha's birthday and I've
been given the great honor of cooking a
Malaysian style veggie curry for the
Prime Minister there's gonna be
thousands of people visiting this temple
this morning so in order to get there on
time
they're very kindly give me a police
escort I've had no time to prepare so
anything could happen
I suppose my biggest worry is that I
haven't tested this dish yet I'm gonna
cook on the fly
agar agar on the spur of the moment
that's the danger though all of the
ingredients used by the temples army of
cooks other nated so I'm going to have
to make do with whatever is left over
[Music]
are you good did you see aubergine
cauliflower tomatoes along side the
leftover veg kitchen boss Masood
bloopers laid out the dried spices that
form the basis of all her curries
turmeric curry powder and then red
chilli star anis cinnamon and some
coriander seeds
to give this curry a real Malaysian
fusion twist I'm adding a good thick
slug of coconut milk it's a hard balance
too because the Malaysian tradition has
got a strong indian influence and the
chinese influence said they've got the
spicy with the sweetness as well so I'm
hoping that tamarind and the coconut
have sort of helped take some that heat
out of the curry but things are about to
get a lot hotter in here the Prime
Minister's aides are in the building and
they seem worried that I might be about
to poison the PM
[Music]
make sure they put this thing safe trust
me
it's safe yeah definitely you'd like to
taste it certainly it's like the food
please
[Music]
you like that what about grumpy bollocks
Oh does he like it you like it thank you
I can honestly say that's a first for me
hopefully
mrs. Roopa will be more enthusiastic so
the food police have been in about a
taste it's really very nice let's hope
it tastes very nice Wow please King
around here
so she says more salt it means no salt
you sure yeah thank God for that
two seconds we'll start plating up mr.
grouper
close your eyes with the p.m. and his
wife in place in the Grand Hall his
elite bodyguard is standing by to take
us through come to the top yeah ready
right do we serve it first prime
minister or the monkey let's go lead the
way mrs. Rupert when we go in I'm gonna
give you the tray and I'll serve it for
you
what's the stairs Missy group has never
met the p.m. so want her in there with
me mrs. roofer
mrs. Ruby come on baby Kamini that
coming from come on the palace is
waiting for you Missy Rupa let's go baby
Hey good afternoon sir ladies and
gentlemen welcome primary sir absolute
pleasure
pretty good to see madam pleasure good
to see you chief good to see this is a
Indian style Malaysian vegetable curry
sir thank you you happy yeah very very
good
thank you I'm trying to say what you
think best wishes please enjoy
sir that's a pleasure thank you I wish
indeed it's crazy out there
no she's happy that's the most important
Prime Minister's very happy
[Music]
yeah 30 seconds thank you I love the way
everyone's pushing around no macaroni no
fish and chips
we're in Malaysia for God's sake
extraordinary it's been a buzz cooking
for the p.m. and his wife and it's yet
another Malaysian auntie has helped me
mean it yes take care my dolly